now what's going on with china i mean
that would be the big that would be the
big kahuna i think why don't they just
go buy
500 billion dollars worth of bitcoin too
much accountability right
if china went and bought 500 billion
with a bitcoin that would be about 50
percent of circulating supply right now
uh one so i don't think they could
actually execute it but let's just say
that was their intention uh whether they
said it or not i think the price of
bitcoin would go to half a million bucks
right because if you had basically
come in and try to buy half the supply
right if you go back bitcoin went from
10 000 in october of 2020 to by march or
april it had peaked at like 64 000 65
000 right so basically 600 percent
increase in a matter of six months or
less and what really was driving that
was institutions started to come into
the market and they basically were
saying i want
bitcoin so i'm willing to pay ten
thousand dollars and a bunch of
bitcoiners about 70 percent of the
people who held it so i'm not selling it
to you at ten thousand dollars say okay
i'll pay ten thousand oh nope now eleven
twelve fifteen twenty twenty five thirty
all and it kept going up and every time
that they would increase their bid it
would unlock a little bit of liquidity
from people who were long-term holders
but we didn't get massive unlock until
we got up over fifty thousand dollars
and so that was only probably if i had
to guess
probably single digit billions went in
to the asset right like like at that
time and how much leverage is in this
space
i think that the leverage in the
crypto uh market in general is still
like relatively high uh there's been
some flushes that have been pretty
healthy uh right now specifically i
think that it's still
on the higher end what i
think people don't appreciate though is
there's a big difference between uh
almost what i'll call um
new leverage versus old leverage that's
a good way to think about it the new
leverage is like if you can go on a
derivatives platform and put 50x
leverage 100x leverage that's very
different than going on a kind of a
traditional derivatives exchange right
and being able to put you know kind of
light leverage or two or three maybe
four or five times leverage and so what
i think ended up happening uh at a
number of times in bitcoin and crypto's
life cycle is that uh
fairly
inexperienced people saw leverage and as
like most things they said this looks
amazing and get rich quick so they
started to use these kind of exotic high
leverage products but they're not
experts at it and so the experts they're
using kind of much less leverage and
they're going ahead and doing it but
we've seen time and time again how do
you get a 50 flush in prices in a single
day
it's leveraged getting wiped out just
liquidations just right down through an
order book and so i think that that's
been a problem it does seem to be
improving a little bit some of the
platforms have taken away you know 100x
leverage type stuff and they're like
okay maybe we should only have 20 right
which is still kind of crazy but like uh
at least one and a half times leverage
is a problem yeah yeah
but but like you can see right anything
greater than one yeah you can just see
how this is becoming a bigger um kind of
focus of the industry the other thing
that i'll say is uh a lot of people
forget that the grayscale bitcoin trust
which now is trading at a 25 discount to
nav yeah which is unbelievable pretty
significant
uh they were probably one of the biggest
drivers of the price increase from
bitcoin from 10k to 60 initially because
what was happening was a lot of these
wall street guys were coming in with big
dollars they were giving money to
grayscale in the private placement
grayscale was then taking that money and
going and buying in the market when they
would buy in the market though they were
buying up to a hundred and fifty percent
of all the bitcoin being produced in a
single day according to the mining
reward so you have a buyer in the market
that's buying more than what's being
mined yeah it's kind of like a share
buyback almost right where it just it
artificially increases the prices yes
and then there's no redemption function
so people couldn't get their money out
of the fund the only way to get your you
know kind of your money back would be to
sell the shares to somebody else and so
it was kind of this perfect storm for
this massive increase in bitcoin price
the big question ends up being what
happens now right like where where does
the
mstrs trade where do they trade at yeah
the no i'm saying like
where will they trade at in the coming
years like mstr it's all correlated to
bitcoin right bitcoin's definitely a big
piece of it now what are they what
percent are they trading at over nav of
their bitcoin so doing their base
business is worthless so right now let's
see in pretty much
2017 2018 all the way up to 2020 uh
microstrategy was trading anywhere
between like 100 to like 210 dollars so
it was kind of like the range that it
went over a number of years for four
years or so obviously uh towards the q4
of 2020 when he first made the first
purchase in august uh he went from
august
he was trading about 125
all the way up by february of 2021 it
was over a thousand dollars so just
massive increase in in price now it's
kind of come down and it's trading
essentially yeah it's like 400 or
something but do you know what it is in
terms of 475 net asset value or no so
the market cap is 490. like if gptc
trades at 25 discount what is mstr trade
out yeah but and again i'm not trying to
write quizzes here
i got the internet you can quiz me all
you want so they own 124 391 bitcoin and
at today's price
that is the cost basis for them is about
3.75 billion according to bitcoin
treasury so maybe slightly off but let's
say this number is correct 3.75 uh
billion dollars today's value is 5.2
billion which is a 1.4 x
4.9 so it's actually trading below
the
just the bitcoin on there uh what were
the numbers again four point nine and
versus five point one or five point two
billion in bitcoin right so like
actually pretty healthy in the sense of
it it is because when i was getting up
to like six seven eight hundred nine
hundred
i traded that thing in a couple days
you wanna know something effing crazy
so
yeah it was nuts i i i don't know i i i
had this stupid idea to put in like i
don't know like 5 million bucks in the
mstr okay
i probably shouldn't be telling the
story but
but i i put like 5 million bucks in mstr
and i forget what it was a year or two
ago or something like that
and i [ __ ] you not
so i i must have executed the trade at
like 3 30 in the afternoon okay i woke
up the next morning and the [ __ ]
thing was up like 25 percent or
something
you saw it all i sold the whole [ __ ]
thing
i said i said holy crap i said i've
never made a million dollars that quick
in my life
i mean even if you look at it in terms
of like okay i went to sleep and then i
woke up i mean i do because like you
know with my with my general stocks i
can make that much money overnight but
do you know to do that on some trade
highly speculative and i was like okay
like this is just stupid this is crazy
out of this damn thing